TREY: WELCOME BACK TO "SUNDAY
NIGHT IN AMERICA" TENSIONS ARE
SKYHIGH BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE
WEST FURTHER ISOLATING MOSCOW
FROM THE REST OF THE WORLD AND
THEN THEY TURN TO CUBA.
RUSSIA CLAIMS INVADED UKRAINE
IN PART BECAUSE IT DIDN'T WANT
WEAPONS POINTED TO THE WEST
THEY DON'T WANT MISSILES
POINTED TO OUR COUNTRY EITHER
IN CUBA IS ONLY 90 MILES FROM
AMERICA WHAT SHOULD OR WILL
OUR RESPONSE BE IF THEY
PARTNER UP AGAIN?
SITTING ON THE HOUSE FOR A
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE JOINING US
NOW, CONGRESSWOMAN WHAT DO WE
KNOW ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND CUBA
QUICK.
>> IT IS A FANTASTIC QUESTION
AND IS VERY TIMELY.
CUBA AND RUSSIA ARE ENJOYING
RIGHT NOW THE WARMEST
RELATIONSHIP THEY HAVE HAD
SINCE THE FALL OF THE SOVIET
UNION.
LAST MONTH VLADIMIR PUTIN SENT
HIS DEPUTY TO GO TO HAVE BEEN
THEY NEGOTIATED TO GO RIGHT UP
AGAINST WHERE RUSSIANS CAN
INTERCEPT EVERY MILITARY
COMMUNICATION THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE REMEMBER HAVE ANNA IS
90 MILES AWAY FROM MIAMI.
AND NOW WITH THE AIRPORTS
THEIR PORTS AND USE THEM
OBVIOUSLY FOR MILITARY
PURPOSES DOWN THE LINE.
SO WHILE RUSSIA IS DOING THAT
DESPICABLE ACT AGAINST THE
UKRAINIANS THEY HAD BEEN
PENETRATING CUBA THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND IT PAYS
OFF BECAUSE CUBA AND VENEZUELA
AND NICARAGUA ALSO VENEZUELA
WHICH IS WORSE THIS WEEKEND
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
ADVISOR GONZALEZ NEGOTIATING
BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS COME UP
WITH THE IDEA WE WILL SHUT OFF
ALL OIL FROM RUSSIA NOW WE'LL
BY FROM THE VENEZUELANS SO WE
ARE PUNISHING ONE TYRANT TO
BENEFIT ANOTHER.
DO YOU KNOW WHY THE
UNDERPINNING OF THE SITUATION
IS THE FACT IT'S PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY ARE
NOT ALLOWING BIDEN TO DO WHAT
IS MORALLY CORRECT IT JUST
HELPS PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE
FREE.
>> WHAT CAN THE US DO WITH
RESPECT TO CUBA TO FAN THE
FLAME WHAT CAN AND SHOULD WE
BE DOING TO CONSENT TO CUBAN
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE FREE?
>> THANK YOU.
THERE IS ONE THING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION COULD DO TO
EMPOWER THE CUBAN PEOPLE TO
COME OUT IN THE STREETS AGAIN
AND SHOUT WHAT THEY WANT TO
ANSWER THEY DID JULY 11 OF
LAST YEAR.
THEY WANT TO BE FREE WE NEED
TO GIVE THEM LEADERSHIP AND
CONDUCTIVITY.
I MISS OFFICE DOCUMENT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT MANY TIMES
ASKING THEM PLEASE GIVE THE
CUBANS THE SAME THING WE TRY
TO GIVE THE UKRAINIANS
INCLUDING THE INTERNET BECAUSE
ONCE IT TURNS OFF THE INTERNET
LIKE THEY DID WITH UKRAINIANS
THOSE THAT WERE BRUTALIZED
THEY WILL KNOW THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS WATCHING AS THE FIRST
THING CONDUCTIVITY AND THEN
SENDING THE MESSAGE THAT WE
ARE THE UNITED STATES WE WILL
NOT ALLOW MILITARY PERSONNEL
FOR THE RUSSIANS TO PAY FOR
ANYTHING IN CUBA AND THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE IS NO
ALLY IN THE CASTRO'S BUT WE
ARE NOT DOING THAT WITH
VENEZUELA OR NICARAGUA OR CUBA.
TREY: CONGRESSWOMAN YOU ARE IN
THE MINORITY OF THE HOUSE FOR
NOW.
IS THERE ANY SENSE THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE ARE
PUTTING PRESSURE ON BIDEN TO
GET TOUGHER WHETHER UKRAINE OR
CUBA IS THERE PRESSURE COMING
FROM THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS?
THAT IS WHO HE IS LISTENING
TO.
>> NO.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THERE IS
A PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT BELIEVES MARXISM IS THE
RIGHT IDEOLOGY AND
UNFORTUNATELY ALWAYS TELL MY
COLLEAGUES THEY HAVE DRINK THE
KOOL-AID ANYTHING THAT HAS TO
DO WITH SOCIALISM MY FRIEND
VICTORIA SPARKED THE ONLY
UKRAINIAN ON THE FLOOR.
THERE IS MY ANCESTORS.
THAT IS WHY THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CANNOT HAVE
BEEN MORE FORCEFUL AGAINST
VLADIMIR PUTIN AGAINST THE
REGIME.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY NEGOTIATING
WE KNOW THAT INFLUENCE IS
NEFARIOUS FOR THE FUTURE OF
AMERICA.
TREY: THANK YOU CONGRESSWOMAN
FOR KEEPING YOUR E